[Music]
all right guys what is your go-to method
to listen to music usually in the car i
think
yeah but like what do you do bluetooth
youtube yeah bluetooth no no so
like radio spotify apple music uh
[ __ ] and pandora
and radio oh my my vinyl turntable
in your car dude magic
it's your steering wheel your car's just
like what the [ __ ]
i mean you could do that at home i
didn't specifically be a real hip-hop
that's how you do it
because we do have a record player in
our house
but yeah so you is uh youtube
pandora or the radio okay you so you
still listen to it right now
how about you youtube or alexa alexa
yeah
because like i have an old car it only
has radio or cd
i use apple music lancashire music or
pandora or spotify
okay all the above because i have the
music i really like i own
and then pandora has some pretty cool
playlists like i've
and then uh spotify some people are just
really good at putting together
playlists too
i like on spotify oh interesting spotify
is good for playlists
yeah cause some people just have good
taste and they curate like a whole bunch
of them like oh man this is a really
good workout list i guess they have joe
rogan too but i forgot
what about you right now yeah all of the
above all the apps you have all your
subscriptions no no no no i don't have
all subscriptions yeah i just have a
spotify
subscription and then youtube as well
for uh music yeah oh okay
what's that one that didn't do well the
one that like jay-z made
i forgot title title no one uses title
never earned it
jay-z who's that well yeah used it
what do you use uh lately youtube it's
just because i'm on youtube watching
other videos i'm just like searching and
it'll just be like a video
and i'm like oh i'll start out the album
the entire time
or album cover i mean i know i pay for
the family plan for our apple music and
it just
for no reason i use it
apple's really good though yeah i know
yeah i like i like just
curating my entire library there i used
to have spotify back when i used to work
at the hospital i loved listening to
spotify
radio because like they just knew the my
life stuff you liked yeah
yeah apple's user interface is complete
[ __ ] to me it's so confusing i can't
find anything i can't even find my own
music on my phone anymore so it's a
magnifying glass you just click and you
can touch whatever you want in there
there you could click your library and
there's all the music that you have
i don't know where the [ __ ] it is it's
at the bottom library well
i won't update it to find out wait what
kind of version do you have
i'm on like 13 versions they're a
library mine does not look like
you click it and you click either your
music or music store
and usually it's it's in one or the
other maybe it's unupdated
i bought me and it begs me to update
look this one hasn't been backed up in
three weeks
and i and i haven't updated it in like
three years seriously
what's stopping you from updating and
doing it because every time i did that
before my battery got all [ __ ] up and
i know they fixed it now but i'm not
that's a good point because they were
they did admit to doing that yeah you
can't trust them that's true
maybe you're still on the shitty version
where it is [ __ ] up your battery
you're in that in between mode before
they fix it
my hamster wheel just just get a new
phone
all right well anyway so we're talking
about spotify here
and they have recently filed a patent
for
technology that will suggest songs based
on your emotions
how they know how i feel do they get
into my fitbit app
so it and apparently it's analyzing
through your vocal patterns
what what that's how they read it yeah
assuming that you're using your vocal
patterns right we repeat that i'm not
sure i understand
so spotify has filed a patent for
technology which doesn't exist yet i
guess i don't know
how patents work but it hasn't been
released to the public
okay at least release to the public but
it will it will
suggest songs based on your emotions
which will be analyzed
through your vocal chords and you'll
start playing like that kind of song
so yeah they're saying like he's feeling
a little horny let's get some marvin
gaye on
so like they're saying kind of like you
know how annoying it is when you're
listening to a playlist
and like a recommended playlist and then
songs come out of nowhere and just
kill the vibe yeah the playlist yeah so
that's what they are trying to solve
like that issue is they're trying to
remedy it with new emotion detecting
technology does that mean it's listening
to you the whole time like for the whole
day
or is it when you're like plenty of
happy music but then they can tell no
this [ __ ] ain't happy he's angry
you know is it like just been in there
or is it the whole day's been listening
to you
sometimes like it's like like if we're
having people over something
nikki's like steve go have alexa do this
[ __ ] and like i'm already trying to do
something else and so i'm like
alexa can you [ __ ] play this but i
don't want her to play angry rage music
or metal at my party
it's a stupid idea if i ever heard one
bullseye
stephen why did you play this why did
you do that i asked you to play com
music and i don't [ __ ] know what
they're doing anymore
but yeah so they say the patent explains
that it is common for
a media streaming application to include
features that provide personalized media
recommendations to a user
so they said that the voice recognition
will
allow the application to understand age
and gender and contextual
clues such as vocal strain and rhythm to
give an insight into the mood of the
user
what is the sound of a gender it just
seems like something
it just seems like a feature that you
would just play with like it doesn't
seem like it's a real
like it would give you the real result
you would just [ __ ] with it all day like
you'll just be
embedded in the app i don't even know
how it sounds like play a song
from my day please oh these are all stop
drop got it
that's true though because uh they could
now have stats like 20
of our users are unhappy fifty percent
yeah yeah just like a stat reading thing
more data yeah yeah that's true new
currency like
data is gold and tech world
he's also my favorite character on the
goonies he's my favorite star trek
character personally
i don't have seen goonies in a long time
then there's a character he's the asian
guy i thought you were gonna say star
trek
or star trek i mean she obviously saw
star trek
though recently i haven't seen it i know
but because you didn't get it yeah
yeah i didn't get it i don't know i just
saw the new ones that he liked
oh yeah the the yeah but star trek
people don't like those though
they don't like those yeah i like the
first one you like the first one oh okay
if we're gonna talk about star trek and
technology yo that beaming [ __ ] though
dude what is that gonna when is that yo
beat me up scotty
[ __ ] light years away from earth i
wanna teleport
it's so bad they can do it with
lightning so what if they [ __ ] up and
then like they don't put you back
together well and there's like a fly
inside the machine too and then you're
half fly have to
what a great movie well that's gonna
happen but they'll hopefully they'll try
on old people first
i thought they were under that wasn't
that a discrepancy oh [ __ ]
we're gonna be old with teleportation
how they were like it could never be
possible because in order for it to work
you'd be killing yourself
and then rebuilding yourself and it
wouldn't be the same
[Music]
faster again no i mean it's well i guess
technically yeah but
you'd still have the same genetic uh
dysfunctions that you previously
i used to want to be immortal but um i
take that back now because i think i
like reincarnation
because like i get to just do this over
again you know what i mean like you see
himself though like you want to be a
tarantula and be like
turn it to a different time different
body i'm just gonna [ __ ] reset and
learn it all over again well you want to
start literally over and over yeah but
like as time goes on or do you want to
go in different times like back and
forth well if we could go back in time i
guess so but it doesn't really matter
because it's all lifetime like it could
be i could be a caveman
or i could be in the renaissance it
doesn't matter right but i think you're
not particularly
immortal yeah it's i think my like
what's probably happening is like my
soul might be immortal so there's a
memory there but then um
yeah like resetting is kind of fun
because the experience is fun
like it's like first like your first hit
of marijuana
like we spend the rest of our chat like
time
trying to get that first and then it
doesn't we don't get it right
and then oh i just talked about for me
because i had a great experience at
mcdonald's
and i was eating three hamburgers and i
was like i'm not
full yet and this is amazing
and then i'm like oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
never happened again right so imagine
being able to relive that moment and
discovering weed all over again for the
very first time
but you have no memory of the remember
[ __ ] times you did it
as a previous bart you would want to be
yourself but a tarantula is that what i
got
no um for me uh that was one thing like
my mom would always try to scare me
about of why i should be buddhist
because she was like
do you want to just reincarnate and turn
to all these different animals over and
over and over
or do you want to be enlightened and
transcend the reincarnation cycle and
i'm like
reincarnation sounds kind of fun so if
i'm a perfect saint and it takes me
stealing a couple things
maybe robbing a couple of people to have
enough sins to keep reincarnating i'll
probably keep doing that
damn wait so what happens after you're
enlightened
then you become like buddha as you're
out of the wheel and then so now you're
like this
uh like a shape-shifting character that
can transcend from any world to any
world is that beyond the human
yeah because they'll go like like you're
an alien at that point yeah so from like
the buddhist perspective so simulation
theory just [ __ ] stole buddhism
that's what that sounds like
this is like the hierarchy of the wheel
you do have some sort of hell
but then even in it you can reincarnate
out of there like everything has a
lifespan
so you have hell and then you have like
all like the
s cell organisms all the way to more
complex organs like humans
then in buddhism at least the one my mom
taught me even
gods still reincarnate so the christian
god
has only been a christian god for a
million years and probably still has
another million years to go so that guy
will keep existing but if he doesn't
work on himself
he's also gonna get into the
reincarnation he can let himself go
you can let himself go and then he
himself also being reincarnated so you
have to keep transcending until you're a
buddha
but then so like depending on how many
sins you commit
it's um it's which which layer you get
to go into
so that's why she's like you got to be a
pure innocent boy and then you got to be
a
and then you got to pray all the time so
you could be enlightened but then i'm
like but what if i get too
good because i kind of also like being
horny and if i get into the god realm
then there's no horny time there so like
maybe i should do a couple more sins so
that when i die
i go exactly in the right spot and if
you have a kid like
me you're like i don't want to be human
i want to be a lizard dude
then you probably got a roster so it's
like what do i got to do to be a lizard
slapper mama people think that it's an
insult like oh no
or like it's going to scare a kid like
you don't want to come back a lizard do
you
and i'm like i love geckos
i love that [ __ ] how much crime do i got
to do to be a lizard
in the cycle of like if you end up
becoming an animal you
have to keep being animals at that point
or can you become a human have you even
lightened that up
animals no so if you're an animal you're
a good animal so you don't want to
become a god
right from wrong you gotta go you gotta
go to animal church
peter's been saying this guys you're
gonna be oh
animal church you just catch them one
day in the bushes
yeah [ __ ] worshiping yeah we don't
know what they're doing like an animal
preacher
do